can you talk a little bit about
particularly in the last three weeks
the uh hypotheses and discussions about
the origins of this
virus have gone i i don't want to say
that it's gone mainstream
but there's been significantly more
discussion including in places where we
were not originally seeing it
my understanding of the spectrum of what
is possible would be on the one hand
this had nothing to do with any lab even
as a pit stop
all the way to this was designed as a
bio weapon and deliberately released
i think it's important no matter what we
explore
to not claim something to be likely
until we
have reason to believe that it's likely
but what do you make of the change in
that discussion over the last few weeks
and sort of the state of that question
yeah so let's talk about the science and
where we are
first on the science and then i will
talk about the discussion yeah so you
actually
really laid out the spectrum well i
could have just been a a standard animal
to human
species jump very common it's how we
get ebola it's how we got zika this is
pretty much the most common way
that we get novel infections all the way
to it was a bio weapon
designed to cause a global epidemic
you know but that so basically the way i
look at it bio weapon design
incredibly unlikely um a bit more likely
is it was it was in a lab now it could
have been a naturally occurring virus
people were studying in the lab and
there was an accidental leak that is
more likely
or it wasn't deliberately designed as a
bio weapon but they were working on gain
of function
and they caused a virus to become more
lethal and then it leaked you know a
little bit less likely but still on the
possibility range
most likely just based on kind of
experience historical that
there was an animal to human jump though
there's a species of animals probably
bats maybe there's a different
intermediary and and humans got infected
the reason i say that's most likely
because again that's how it usually
happens
but here's the bottom line i don't know
the answer
and i would argue that probably no one
else does either i mean if it was a lab
leak maybe a small number of people do
but i certainly don't no one else in the
united states does so what do we need to
do and first of all why is it important
it is important we want to know where
this virus came from we want to
understand it
not just because it helps us manage this
one but prevent future ones
but the other part is we have got to
stop politicizing this like
my god at this point we have managed to
take this thing that's a very
complicated and important scientific
question
and people are talking about it as
though like if you're a democrat you
believe one thing in a republican you
believe
another i just don't know the right
answer we need to investigate it we need
to push china to give us
more cooperation we need to have the u.s
intelligence and other intelligence
agencies investigated
we really do need to get to the bottom
bottom of this again if i were a betting
person i'd say probably came from an
animal but we're not we're not making
bets here
we should actually sort it out